- We are celebrating summer today.
And I think we all
deserve rest, relaxation
and a change of scenery this year.
My next guest has us covered
with all sorts of great escapes
you can take to splash
into summer and feel good about doing it.
Let's welcome back The
Travel Mama herself,
Emily Kaufman everybody!
(audience cheers and claps)
- Hey everybody, hey Kelly!
It's good to be back with you.
- You look beautiful.
- Thank you.
- I love the dress, the hair
- Thank you, thank you.
- Everything, the lipstick,
it looks so great.
So people still have some reluctance
about traveling right now, right?
- You know, they do.
The number one question
is whether it's safe
to get out there and travel.
And the good news is that destinations
and hotels have created great protocol
and procedures in place to keep us safe.
And I've got some trip
options that will suit
everybody's comfort level.
- All right, all right, don't
threaten us with a good time.
Okay, let's start with the
most conservative travelers.
What do you suggest?
- You know there are people
that still are not ready
to get on a plane, and I
totally understand that.
And a great way that you
could travel right now
is an RV vacation.
An RV vacation is ideal because
you're limiting your
interaction with other people,
you're with your family that you've been
in your bubble with, but
you're getting outside instead
of being indoors with work and school
and all the stuff that goes along with it.
You're outside having some
fun and many campsites
and national parks are following
COVID protocol as well,
with limiting the number of
vehicles that can come on
and the number of people.
And you want to make sure that you're
looking to rent an RV with a great company
like RVshare.
RVshare is the first and
largest peer to peer platform
that connects RV renters with RV owners.
And they've got more than
a hundred thousand vehicles
to choose from.
And you can do things like be rustic
and get off the grid or
stay at a glamping place.
Something like a Sun RV Resort.
They've got more than 160 locations
throughout the United States and Canada.
And one tip to remember,
you need reservations ahead of time.
You can't just show up at a campsite,
and summer's the busiest
time so plan ahead.
- Absolutely, especially now if there's
limited amount of space.
- Exactly.
- I love this vacation if it
were pandemic times or not,
this sounds awesome.
- Yes.
- Well good news, Emily
is not just telling us
about ideal vacations,
she is actually helping us
give some away today.
So anyone in the house seats interested
in an RV getaway this summer, anybody?
(audience cheers and claps)
Yeah, okay I see some takers.
All right, let's get
our light show shuffle
underway right now.
When I say go, the lights will flash
on random audience members
until one lands on someone.
Whoever it stops on is getting
the ultimate family vacation,
which includes $5,000
towards a luxury RV rental
of your choice from RVshare.
And this will cover your luxury
motor home, food and gas.
Plus, you're gonna get to
stay at Sun RV Resorts,
which is awesome.
So let's get to this, Joe are you ready?
- [Joe] Yes, ready.
- All right, all right.
And, go!
(intense music)
Woo! When's it gonna stop?
When's it gonna stop?
Oh! When's it gonna stop?
Hi! Okay, look at her! (laughs)
- Oh my God, thank you!
- What's your name and have you ever done
RV traveling before?
- No, I'm gonna cry!
My name's Jocelyn and I've
never done RV traveling.
- Oh my gosh, Jocelyn!
I love you right now
and I kinda want to go
on your vacation with you, you seem fun!
- Oh my gosh, thank you guys!
I have a family of four,
I have two little ones
and ever since "Toy
Story 4" they've wanted
to go on an RV and this is amazing!
Thank you so much! (crying)
- Absolutely, oh my gosh.
Have so much fun.
I love you, she's so excited.
All right well, Emily, what's next?
- You know a lot of people
are ready to get on a plane.
- Uh-huh.
- And they're doing it
safely, with masks and shields
and following the protocol.
And a great getaway in the United States,
it's as tropical as you can get
while still feeling the arms
of Uncle Sam wrapped tightly
around you, is Hawaii.
- Yeah.
- Wailea, Maui is as
tropical as you can get.
And it's a nice, easy non-stop plane ride
from so many places.
Hawaii is one of the top
destinations being booked,
and Wailea is a great walkable community
on the south shore of Maui.
And the Fairmont Kea
Lani is a great example
of a hotel that's
implemented terrific protocol
in place with interactions like being like
contact-less check-ins, deep cleaning
and those kind of things.
My husband and I went there
for our 30th anniversary
and had a blast it's located
on the coveted south shore
of Maui in Hawaii in Wailea.
And it's Hawaii's only all-suite
with villa and luxury oceanfront rooms.
And they've been known for
their distinctive dining venues,
bars, gourmet market, three
pools, a comprehensive
spa and wellness program,
and authentic Hawaiian culture,
plus unrivaled access to
one of the best adventures
and beaches across the island.
And when you're planning
your trip to Hawaii,
really important to remember,
they require a safe health application
and screening process.
So you have to have a negative
COVID test uploaded 72 hours
before you board your flight.
So you can go to their
website to check that out
at gohawaii.com.
- Yeah, that's smart.
Keeping everybody safe
while having a good time.
So no one wants to go
to Hawaii here, right?
No one would be interested
in that right, no?
(audience cheers and claps)
Okay, you are?
Okay, cool.
This is for a six day luxury vacation
to the Fairmont Kea Lani in Wailea Maui.
And it includes an ocean view
suite, daily breakfast for two
a poolside cabana, which I
love, dinner for two at Ko
and airfare provided by the
Wailea Resort Association.
So let's give away another trip.
So Joe hit it, go!
(intense music)
(audience claps)
Where's it gonna land?
Woo!
Yeah! (laughs)
All right so what's your name?
And are you excited?
Have you ever been to Hawaii?
- No I haven't, my name is Julia.
My husband and I are actually
coming up on an anniversary
so we thought about Hawaii.
- Oh my, well you know what?
I am a genie today and
your wish is granted.
(audience applauds)
All right well enjoy it girl!
Hey thank you so much Emily, for today.
This was awesome.
- Thank you.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
And congratulations, 30
years, that's amazing.
- Thanks!
- Yes, absolutely.